we got a video right here that came in
from somebody let's see what's going on
this is our first king under sting it
okay oh yeah
a goat love I well this is Brad exotic
this shit's dope a goat love ice
beautiful goats you ever jumped on ice
bath before yeah man
I love them dude I'll go under me too I
love them you won't go all the way I'll
go all the way down there you I thrive
in the cold no I love it dude if you
thrived in the cold you would have
stayed in Denver dude no dude I thrived
in the cold not at altitude bro get your
facts right I told you this both of them
test same thing he told you this in
attacks so now don't do well at high
altitude okay now you know [ __ ] wear
your dress like a medic in World War men
all this [ __ ] busboy at the front
[ __ ] Boston Red Sox rap like God
somebody get this guy a real job those
are my baths he looked like the oldest
managers like that yeah you know man
yeah bro its policy policy
yeah dude back off these Bart Simpson
shirts I got over here okay
dude I love spencer's man I know you do
see how they stay hoping though I never
saw anybody buy anything ever mmm no one
ever bought anything all right like you
could get some lava lamps and that's
about it
you get a beavis and butt-head status'
some Selena shirts mm-hmm all right
Peter a lot of posters yeah you get good
posters in there are kids still into
posters I am oh well I'm not a kid just
admitted that you [ __ ] have some
issues with growing
you're supposed did you have grown-up
cat did get posters um I used to have a
poster of Britney Spears and a poster of
Paul Walker and fast and furious my
[ __ ] love Paul Walker also Walker is
the love of my life well I used to be
right yes
did you go to any memorials form or
anything like that like what was it like
for you I did not go to any memorials
but I did loiter outside of a Tapioca
Express when I found out that he died
and there's a bunch of like Asian dudes
with like modded cars so it's basically
my version died in a Porsche died in a
Porsche GT Porsche GT a thing is the
Widowmaker it is oh the car he was
driving was Abby sings a piece of [ __ ]
and but I think his buddy was driving
got a [ __ ] they'll be like me letting
you drive my car and then I died you've
got a [ __ ] well I'll just tell you
right now that that's how it would go
down no I know you ever let me drive
that bastard son be the end of your life
look at that [ __ ] oh great car great car
dude was yeah well no you can't still
get him know killed him dude I know his
buddy killed him his buddy killed him
huh his buddy killed the card and kill
him the buddy did both of them did yeah
and that was God Walker would've liked
me definitely I think more than you know
I don't think so I don't think so kind
of cars and then you know you gotta have
like a gay vibe I feel like you always
try to massage his feet yeah dude you
have a plus sign on your head dude okay
enough bananas on yours
yeah dude your Nana huh
yeah but Dennis yeah and this is a
[ __ ] signature ad dude there's a nice
hat it is a nice hat I kind of like
thank you very much dude oh you like the
banana it's a little plus sign hat hey
me add me buddy
[Laughter]
you know if you take two straight man
and put you between them bro that's gay
right they gay man oh oh yeah if you
weren't a damn plus sign bro why did you
why did you go into an ice bath
I'll be back to this why did you give a
nice back to recover man for to recover
from some of a lot of strong Fitness
I've been doing a lot of adult activity
intense training what else um nice ice
bath did you read comic books better
line up the ice bath dude I did a lot of
high-pressure training you freak
you still with that trainer's just blown
out you know Nicki Minaj trainer Meyer a
delay that lady off yeah she wanted me
to wear a thong and get a My Little Pony
tan today she's trying to you into
Instagram thought really a business
decision
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]